I didn't realize what undocumented or
being undocumented meant until I got to
high school when people are getting
ready to get their driving permit or
also apply to college all my friends
were getting jobs but I couldn't because
I didn't have a Social Security number
[Music]
something that realized very young was
that getting pulled over means a lot
more when you're undocumented because
they could have much more serious
consequences it can mean separation from
your family we've heard of people that a
ticket can lead to deportation when my
friend run over a stop sign and the
police pulled us over I would just text
everybody I know that like okay I'm on
this intersection and then if I don't
text you back in ten or twenty minutes
how you know these nonprofit
organization if you're out and you're in
the car and you see the police you
automatically become struck with fear
because you just want to be okay one of
the hardest parts is knowing that
nothing is guaranteed you don't know if
you'll come home and your parents will
be there where if you'll make it home
that day when you leave the house and
you leave your parents or your siblings
you don't know if that will be the last
time that you saw them you don't know if
when you come back home they'll be there
so you don't know if that last goodbye
you shared with your family being your
mom your brother your sister your cousin
is the last goodbyes that you share
you're away you're at the grocery store
you're at school and you may not be able
to come back or when you do come back
your parents might not be there the fear
and anxiety is something that you learn
and you try to deal with from a very
young age and then there's when you
graduate high school and you've worked
your butt off to be able to get that 4.0
GPA to get you that scholarship that
financial aid and once you apply you
realize that you might have to withdraw
because they find out that you're
undocumented or you might be forced to
pay out-of-state tuition on top of that
no financial aid and this could possibly
mean you're not being able to anymore go
to that school or program you know as
undocumented folks you can't really
think of anything in long term there's
never really been a sense of stability
and sometimes it's hard to invest
yourselves because in my mind I never
know like in five years in a year in
couple months where will I be so it's
hard to plan ahead for life and it's
hard to just work towards something
[Music]
this morning Secretary Napolitano
announced new actions my administration
will take to mend our nation's
immigration policy to make it more fair
more efficient and more just
specifically for certain young people
sometimes called dreamers now these are
young people who study in our schools
they play in our neighborhoods they're
friends with our kids they pledge
allegiance to our flag they are
Americans in their heart in their minds
in every single way but one on paper so
after several years of advocating and
pushing for a piece of legislation 2012
comes around and we finally have a
program for undocumented youth it gave a
lot of undocumented youth a sense of a
little more freedom and it was hope for
a lot of us this is the first time where
we suddenly felt a sense of belonging
like all the hard work was finally about
to pay off and maybe lead to an
opportunity to access citizenship or a
more long-term solution daca happened
because of grass roots community it is
undocumented folks himself who made
darker happen there's hope because a lot
of people are just realizing and then as
we come together in
like we'll find a way White House
officials tell ABC News that the
president is seriously considering
ending a program that provides legal
status to hundreds of thousands of
undocumented immigrants who came to the
United States as children the move the
president is considering would put
nearly 800,000 undocumented immigrants
in danger of being deported and 2017 is
very hard to process how you're able to
live here you know
you grew up in this country with friends
family with this culture that you used
to and all of the sudden it just the
country just doesn't want to
knowing that Sokka maybe repealed I
think has increase in hyeon's a lot of
people's worries if doc is removed a
hundred thousand people are gonna go
back to a life of anxiety fear and
uncertainty because they can lose their
jobs they might have to withdraw from
certain college programs this could also
mean that they are now that much more
vulnerable to deportation immigration is
a natural occurrence it is gonna happen
and you know we have just we have build
up from it we have seen progress in the
house and just because there's a little
bit of reclining doesn't mean the
progress is gonna stop our main goal is
to how about we deserve we've been in
this country we worked hard we belong
here in the midst of all this I think
it's important to look around and
realize that we have such a big
community of advocates and allies that
really want to see it succeed
immigrants always find a way and where
there is no way we create one and I
believe that that's what's really made
us so strong we need to look to that
same resilience to be able to get
through what lies ahead by any means
necessary we're not going to go anywhere
and we just have to make sure the rest
of the country gets that message
[Music]